today we're going to talk about one of
the best remedies you can do for dry
wrinkly
hands
now especially in the winter when it's
dry out and you don't have enough
vitamin d your hands can get extremely
dry but there's a lot more to this and
there's some great things you can do to
resolve this problem and for those of
you that are wondering if i'm growing a
beard yes i am starting to grow a beard
i'm going to try it out and see what
happens now when people start putting
all sorts of lotions on their hands
they don't realize that everything you
put on your hand
doesn't just disappear it doesn't
evaporate it gets sucked into the pores
goes in the bloodstream and goes right
to your liver so you really want to make
sure that what you're putting in your
skin
is safe 22
of all uh personal care products are
petroleum-based
which includes solvents like benzene
includes mineral oil which by the way
will pull out a lot of the key fat
soluble vitamins like vitamin a
d
e
and vitamin k leaving your hands very
dehydrated dry
red
cracking and even itchy then we have the
chemicals in tap water i mean you have
fluoride
chlorine which are very very harsh
uh on your skin not just your hands but
your face your entire body when you take
a shower really good idea to get a
shower filter but our skin is constantly
bombarded by all sorts of chemicals and
things that
make us look older now if we compound
that
by our current situation where people
have to wash their hands
20 times a day you can imagine uh what
this does to the hands now i'm going to
be totally upfront i'm not against
washing your hands i think you should
definitely be washing your hands to
decrease the spread of viruses i wash my
hands very frequently so i'm not against
that however
if you find that your hands are
completely dried out
red
itchy
cracking
looking scaly and old there's some
important things you can do
other than just going down to the local
drugstore and getting some lotion and
putting it on your hands and then
finding out that wow within five minutes
it's right back to being dry again what
you have to be aware of is that there
are thousands of different types of
species or microbes friendly microbes
living on your hands
and all around your body and yes you can
call them germs but they're friendly
germs okay you also have friendly
funguses about 14 different funguses
that are living on your hands now what's
interesting is they've done different
assessments
on this microbiome living on the surface
of our skin and they isolated different
types of microbes in different places
and i found it interesting that the area
of the body that had the most
diversified fungal species is actually
on your heels
fascinating but on your hands you have
about 14 different types of funguses and
these are
friendly we call this micro relationship
a symbiotic relationship
symbiotic means working together having
some mutual benefits back and forth the
microbes protect us we give them a home
to live then you have all these
different types of microbes that have a
symbiotic relationship with each other
so they have to learn to live together
right i mean i wish we as a human race
could actually be more symbiotic
some people just have a very difficult
time tolerating differences different
cultures different viewpoints and
different beliefs so in order to have a
symbiotic relationship we have to have a
lot of tolerance of differences and you
need to have the awareness
that these
so-called germs are not harmful and we
don't necessarily have to have this
anti-germ or microbe viewpoint because
we can't even exist without these
microbes they actually help our survival
they make vitamins they give us immune
protection and without them being on
your hands the pathogens
the the bad microbes start to develop
and they create a lot of problems
and there's also another interesting
thing you can have
non-pathogenic microbes
and change the environment
like make the environment more stressful
and have those non-pathogenic microbes
turn into
pathogens
so just a change of environment will
alter
the type of microbes that are living on
your body apparently when you stress
them out some of them go a little bit
crazy so it's very very important to
have a good environment a healthy
environment for your microbes to live
and not continually stress them out and
this is why we get to the remedy there's
a couple things that you'll add to the
skin that will make a huge difference in
having these microbes start thriving now
the other thing i want to bring up is
the ph of your skin
it's not alkaline it's acidic it's
between 4 and 4.5 so
that's actually pretty acid and if the
ph goes to high
becomes more alkaline
all sorts of things happen your skin
starts to swell it can become inflamed
so you really need to understand what
you put on your body so you don't put
the wrong thing and end up creating a
problem now i do want to mention one
other thing and this is what i try to
educate people on over and over and over
your external skin the way you look your
hair your nails are a reflection of
what's going on inside what you eat
what you avoid what you do to your body
to keep it healthy so what i show you
for a remedy will help you but you
really need to focus also on your diet
internally and so every part of your
body externally can look youthful
and yes i'm talking about lowering your
carbohydrates and doing in a minute
fasting two very powerful things that
will slow down the oxidation or the
rusting out of your tissues because it's
the sugar the refined flour products
like in grains as well as the so-called
vegetable oils which like the soy canola
oil that is in so many of our foods that
just makes our skin especially age at a
very fast rate so there's two
main
goals
for the hands okay
number one we want to of course avoid
things that are making them dry and
older so in other words if you're using
lotions that have
products you know just don't use those
anymore and as a side note i have a
greenhouse so i'm working with soil all
day long i learned very very quickly
that you must wear gloves because if you
dig your hands into
soil with all the clays and all the
different um minerals and the microbes
living in the soil where you can dry out
your hands so fast so you have to wear
gloves if you're working with soil or if
you're working with pottery or you're
being exposed to different chemicals at
work i know of one gentleman that was
working with solvents
and
these solvents just pulled out
all the vitamin e from his hands and
they were literally red
cracking
blistery and so any type of
petroleum-based mineral oil
solvents
pull out all these fat-soluble vitamins
and so you better put it back in and so
the two main goals i would recommend is
number one put back into your hands
these fat cyber vitamins vitamin a
d
e
and vitamin k and number two recognize
that you have these friendly microbes
living on your skin they're symbiotic
and don't try to kill them continually
without allowing them to be
re-established so it's very very
important between the constant washing
in the hands and
exposure of the chemicals that you allow
the hands to reestablish their microbes
and even nourish the microbes with what
i'm going to show you next so here's the
remedy it's going to be a blend of just
three simple ingredients okay
one is you're going to use egg yolks
okay you're not going to put the white
of the egg you can use one egg yolk put
a little bowl what's so special about an
egg yolk an egg yolk
is an embryo and it contains
all of the fat soluble
vitamins as well as other essential fats
that it's going to be really hard to get
in other foods and so this egg yolk is
loaded with
retinol vitamin a
vitamin e it has vitamin d
it has vitamin k
it has omega-3 fatty acids and all of
these vitamins are going to be able to
be absorbed into the skin not to mention
it's very high in lucifen and lecithin
really helps to soften up the hands
lecithin also is the antidote to
cholesterol so it helps to break down
cholesterol too and then we have choline
which is another good
nutrient that can help act as a bile
salt actually and help to dissolve some
of these other key fat soluble nutrients
so it can go right into your skin so we
get a little bowl take one egg yolk put
it into the bowl then you're going to
take one teaspoon or 14 grams
of raw honey preferably manuka honey and
you're going to put that in the bowl too
and you're going to just mix it around
now manuka honey is anti-bacterial
anti-viral anti-fungal
it's great for wound healing it's great
as an anti-inflammatory
it's wonderful for your skin plus the
sugar in the honey actually feeds
the microbes and this application that
you're going to mix up and use on your
hands
i only recommend using it like twice a
week because you don't want to make
sugar junkies out of these microbes and
feed them too much sugar but one
strategy for farming is to add some type
of molasses or something into the soil
so these microbes can live because
microbes do eat
carbs microbes are not on the ketogenic
diet all right so now the last
ingredient
is two tablespoons
for 26 grams of extra virgin
olive oil make sure you get the real
stuff okay not the fake stuff i've done
videos on that if you haven't seen that
video i put it down in the description
all right so we have the egg yolk the
honey and the olive oil all right so you
mix it all up really really good and
then you apply it to your hands okay
for 20 minutes don't wash your hands
right away
let it soak in
okay let it heal
let it feed the microbes and
re-establish some of these microbes and
then after 20 minutes just rinse your
hands off you're going to find that your
hands are extremely soft and they feel
really good and i recommend doing it
right before you go to bed so that way
all night long you're not washing your
hands you're just allowing them to heal
and i would recommend doing this two
times a week
all right so now that you have that
remedy
the next video i'm going to recommend
has to do with anti-aging and looking
useful if you haven't seen that video
you definitely need to check it out i
put it up right here